so I'm curious to know there are like so
many stunts in this series what was the
most difficult for both of you can I
answer for you yeah I think it was the
bathroom one yeah right right you are
right yeah because it was all day
non-stop it was all day non-stop and it
was a small space and we were in that
tiny little cubicle and I had to get a
guy's head and put it in the toilet but
not bump him not make sure that he
didn't hurt himself yeah yeah because
he's he's following your league because
he's following my lead but so it's a
very strange thing for an actor to be in
a situation where it's like Max just
wants to shove this head in the toilet
she don't care if he's hitting his head
on the way down she didn't care but
Laura is like [ __ ] I'm like that sorry
sorry
sorry I wasn't bumped his head about
five times bless him he was a trooper
yeah I think he dislocated his knee
actually that guy why are you a film
yeah well now I'm hoping for bloopers of
that because that sounds like that was
funny there are Shane we should get
bloopers that's a good idea for real
he's we're getting the thumbs up there
you go
but no for you what was the most
difficult step for you was it jumping
into the water that was so fun I loved
that that was great I'm a big fan of
that moment
um
what was the most difficult
oh you hurt your back so yeah but I was
just walking
it wasn't even in a sense
you had to shoot us down the next day I
like leaned over and took a wonky step
and my back was like you're gonna be
laying down for three days buddy but
then you did have to shoot a stunt the
neck that was weird that's true yeah I
had to like lay on the ground and like
pretend to be in a fire fight that was
so the last episode that was tough for
you yeah but you're such a cheaper you
did it over and over and over again I
can't believe it
thank you for that this stunt doubled
the 99 of the work over those three days
they were like coming we're gonna shoot
your face real quick and I was like and
they were like you're done go home
so I love uh the fact that like when we
first meet Owen he's listening to a
Taylor Swift song I'm a Swifty so that
like instantly won me over
um
I know I mean those tickets sold out so
I'm confident there's like millions and
billions but oh yeah she was on
everybody's Spotify rap everybody
but I'm so curious to know what would be
Owen and Max's theme songs individually
I was listening to this song loads
called blood in the cut oh yeah do you
know blood in the car yeah by grandson
yeah it's such an amazing song and
before I went to set every day I
listened to that song really get me into
that cool yeah that's really cool
that's awesome
um
what's the song does anybody in the room
know the song picture this I'm a piece
of [ __ ] I'm gonna be good you guys know
that song
biscuit there's a piece of [ __ ] yeah
picture this some anyway it doesn't
matter that's your song but something
about like run the jewels something
about like Killer Mike maybe
um
yeah that's just I can't picture the
name of it I'm like you're right now I
can't think of the time I know I'm
terrible at thinking of titles of songs
sorry it's a good song I've given you my
um my problem with blood in the guts are
great
it's like that is a good song
um I did want to ask Laura I so I loved
you and Downton Abbey a new era and I
was curious which is more challenging
like a character that's very reserved or
a character like Max that is so like
physical which is the more challenging
type of role
um
I mean they're all challenging to a
point but
comparing those two characters
I know I found I found
um Myrna in Downton more challenging
not that I enjoy spending time with her
I love spending time with her but I
found that more challenging than I did
Max Max I'm like I love getting into the
heads of crazy women I'm like take me
there let me exist inside this crazy
head for five months yeah that's great
and I have a similar question for you
Nora what was it like making that jump
from like rom-coms and to all the boys I
Loved Before and making this jump into
action hero well I mean he's not really
an action hero
he doesn't even want to be he's a lawyer
he's all he's trying to be as an
attorney and like every you know in the
world that he lives in is such a
dangerous one that he finds himself in
these impossible situations where he
barely Gets Out Alive by the skin of his
teeth I love that one when he's in the
car and he's trying to get away from the
body
he drives
two seconds yeah and then smashes the
car and the the
um bag comes up it's such good timing
it's funny it's real funny it's like
just enough time that you're like oh
okay yeah like you know he gets a oh he
doesn't get away he's like he's locked
the car hey he's locked his car we can't
unlock the car like no you never see
another like in bond they never lock the
car no they just walk up to the car and
they're in whereas
Owen locks his car gets back unlocks it
gets him puts his belt on you're right
it's silly and it's a good way to enter
this and it's really real
super fun so the finale is such a
shocking one when you get to that that
final moment
I was like when is season two but I want
to know when you got to that final page
in the script what were both of your
reactions I did I didn't want to
you should delete it delete that you
guys know me right
exactly oh I must have got the received
the wrong pages
now I'm really joking it's what
episode's the character it's a it's a
okay
that's right
um yeah what it was a crazy head uh
Cliffhanger my God
and I immediately was like I was like oh
I wonder what more could you what where
else could you take it it feels like the
perfect kind of I mean who knows what's
gonna happen we actually don't know so
we read the end of the first episode and
anything could move on I was like is
this like a Game of Thrones situation or
is this like deceiving like you don't
you really don't know no I guess we've
got the fact in front of us is that the
show ends and the credits come up and we
don't see Max move so but let's see you
never know
no because she gets shot in in the chest
yeah and people get back together all
the time well well a lot of people have
been shot in the chest do you think your
relationship's done it's no you get back
together oh we'll see maybe maybe who
knows what's gonna happen right Max and
I what happens is Max survives we get
out of it we leave we start a family
we moved to the English Countryside and
everything's really calm and then we
make the holiday number two it's fine
yeah foreign
that's gonna be that's my ending now
that's where that's how it ended
actually we make the holiday number two
it was great
I think we've got mad I think we need
something to eat well thank you very
much that was actually the end of the
interview so thank you both thank you
thank you